بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد كلامنا موصول ودرسنا موصول في كتاب
زاد المعاد من هدي خير العباد للحافظ
الفقيه الامام العلامه شيخ
الاسلام ابن قيم الجوزيه شمس الدين رحمه
الله تعالى هو كتاب حافل معروف
معود
ومعتمد عند العلماء من حين ان الف فطار كل
مطار
واخذه الطلاب والعلماء الى الافاق وحق
ل قد وصلنا فيه الى
ابواب فيه ذكر بعض احكام الجهاد والعهد
والذمه والجزيه وما شابه ذلك وهذه
اشياء موجوده في كتب الفقه وموجوده في كتب
التاريخ
ولعله يحسن بنا ان ننتقل الى سياق مغازيه
عليه الصلاه
والسلام ونكمل في
سيرته عليه الصلاه والسلام
سلام فيقول الحافظ فصل في ترتيب هديه مع
الكفار والمنافقين من حين بعث الى ان لقي
الله عز
وجل زاد
المعاد الشيخ شمس الدين الحافظ ابن القيم
رحمه الله
‏the islamic
world one of the brightest minds in the
hist of islamic schar he wrote المد and
recap on the purpose of this book the
purpose of this book is to mention
the صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏so of confuse حديث
سه
سه is the guidance of the propet محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم his tradition his
ways his rings his
juds that he died upon عليه الصه
والسلام was fin
سه
حديث حديث is anything mention about the
propet الله عليه وسلم
anything it could be at the begin of
islam it could be before he was a
prophet things that were mentioned about
him these are refer to as حث and so
based on
we that
سه
حديث
حثث that been ched things that know the
begin islam at the begin
‏is that which he intend to be emulated
in he intended to be followed to
beed
سلام
حث
حديث regard prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم regarding his manm regarding his
words regarding
‏all even naturala ha he had how many
hairs he had in in his beard how many ha
he had in his head
etc
حديث محد صلى الله عليه وسلم
حديث
سنه
سه
سنه هذه مساله مهمه وذلك
ان العلماء
يقولون كل
سنه
حديث وليس كل حديث سنه ثم احاديث منسوخه
اقوال اشياء حت
ما كان قبل
نبوته وهه تكون احاديث يعني كيف كانت
احوال قبل ان يكون نبيا اشياء قالها اشياء
شهدها هذه احاديث لكنها ليست سنن السنه هو
ما قصد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان يطاع
وان يتبع تعبدا لله سبحانه وتعالى فيها
ورعايه لحدود الله
فهذا الكتاب مقصده
السنه ليس هدف
الكتاب ذكر جميع الاحاديث احاديث كثيره
لكن المقصود من الحديث ذكر السنه اخر ما
كان من عهد رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
في سنته حين ان توفاه الله هذا كان
هديه في الوضوء في الصلاه في الجهاد في
الحج في العمره في هذا هذا هو هدف الكتاب
وذكر شء من سيرته استنباط كثير من الاحكام
منها
so زاد
المعاد مندي خير العباد
صل عليه
وسلم the that
are س gu صلى الله عليه وسلم
notra
narration which have exceptions we have
reached to a chapter
‏this chapter is regarding his
guidance with regards to deing with
those are
non and those hypocrites which ex in
musl
popul
from عليه الصه والسلام و
السلام ف معاملته عليه الص
والسلام مع غير المسلمين ترتيب تنويع
الكفار
ثم جماعه كانوا مناضلين له وثم جماعه من
الكفار كانوا مناضلين عنه عليه الصلاه
والسلام والمعامله
اختلفت
وتغيرت هذه المعامله وتطورت مع تطور
الاحوال الى ان توفاه الله عليه الصلاه
والسلام ف ثم ترتيب في
المعامله هذا الفصل عقده المؤلف رحمه الله
في ترتيب هديه مع الكفار والمنافقين من
حين بعث الى ان لقي الله عز وجل
‏look world
through isam how do we religiously how
are we going to categorize people in a
rough categorization well there is a
general categorization there are those
who are muslim and those who are
not there are different
rings based circumstances the propet
عليه
[Silence]
‏out الله سبحانه
وتعالى واذا لق الذ امن
قوا خلوا الى شياطينهم قالوا معكم انما
نحن
مستهزئون are
not those are
not are
tyes not all
the are those are agress transgress
[Silence]
‏are not musl only because they are af
of the repercussions af you know what
their family might say but they are
sympathetic to islam muslims these are
different types of people and different
tyes
people different through prop صل الله
عليه
وسلم
times there is propaganda that you know
in islam a person is muslim or non
muslim and if a person is a non muslim
automatically they are to get the worst
and they cherry pick different verses of
the but these verses were raled at
different junctions different places
الله سبحانه
وتالى that fight those who disbelieve
for instance or such as which is often
refer an
اسلام from
سبه from س مح
‏are
those any disb what if a person never
heard about isl before they never heard
of it technically they are not believers
so does this verse apply to them as
well and so this is a
distinction that is made by the
scholarship isam has andes different
things different
‏and ultimately this is something that
the scholars of islam specialize in
teaching us and articulating to us and
preserving however in a very general
sense we can look and see that
people there are those who accepted
islam and they went through different
phases and there are those who
isam صلى الله عليه
وسلم يقول رحمه الله تعالى اول ما اوحي
اليه او اوحى اليه ربه تبارك وتعالى ان
يقرا باسم ربه الذي خلقه وذلك اول
نبوته ثم انزل عليه يا ايها المدثر قم
فانذر اول ما اوحى اليه ربه تبارك وتعالى
ان يقرا باسم ربه الذي خلقه يعني ا اول
ايه من سوره العلق اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق
وكاد ان يجمع العلماء على انها اول ايه
انزلت على النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وشذ
بعض العلماء فقالوا اول ما انزل سوره
الفاتحه واول ما انزل بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم لكن هذه روايات لا تثبت ولم يقل
بها المحققون
وانما كما جاء في البخاري ومسلم عن عائشه
ان اول ما انزل عليه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم في غار حراء القصه المعروفه المعهوده
لكل مسلم ومسلمه ان جبريل اتاه فقال اقرا
قال ما انا بقارئ قال ثم اخذني فضمني حتى
بلغ مني الجهد ثم ارسلني فقال لي اقرا قلت
ما انا بقارئ قال ثم اخذني الثانيه
فضمني حتى بلغ مني الجهد ثم ارسلني فقال
اقرا قلت ما انا بقارئ قال ثم اخذني
الثالثه ثم قال اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق
خلق الانسان من علق اقرا وربك الاكرم الذي
علم بالقلم علم الانسان ما لم يعلم هذه
خمس ايات انزلت عليه في
ليله القدر من رمضان
13 سنه قبل هجرته عليه الصلاه والسلام
وبذلك نبئ يعني كان نبيا العلماء يقولون
نبئ
بقرا وارسل بالمدثر
يعني كان
نبيا عندما انزلت عليه اقرا باسم ربك الذي
خلق لا انه لم يؤمر
بالتبليغ لم يؤمر بالتبليغ لم يؤمر
بدعوه
الناس وانما امر
بالتبليغ بقوله يا ايها المدثر قم
فانذر فقال
العلماء نبئ يعني كان نبيا او كان
نبئا باقرا
وارسل كان رسولا بيا ايها المدثر قم
فانذر فارسله
بها
ارسله يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى ارسل النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم بهذه
بفواتح سوره المدثر ثم امره ان ينذر
عشيرته قربين هذه الدرجه الثانيه الدرجه
الاولى لنفسه الدرجه الثانيه قم فانذر
فانذر
سرا من شاء عليه الصلاه والسلام ثم امر
ب
الانذار وانذر عشيرتك
الاقربين فانذر
قومه ثم انذر من حوله من العرب ثم انذر
العرب قاطبه ثم انذر
العالمين فاقام بضع عشره سنه ينذر بغير
قتال يعني قبل الهجره ويؤمر
بالصبر يؤمر بالصبر ق تعالى فاعفوا
واصفحوا حتى ياتي الله بامره ان الله على
كل شيء قدير هذا امر بماذا بالصبر فاعفوا
واصفحوا يعني عن اهل الكتاب وعن غير
المسلمين في
اذاهم قال ثم اذن له في الهجره ثم اذن له
في القتال ثم امره ان يقاتل من
قاتله ثم امره ان يقاتل المشركين حتى يكون
الدين كله
لله ابن القيم رحمه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله comm
قران
comm س
الق that
was حرا حرا
رمضان في ليله القدر انزلناه في ليله
القدر انزلناه في ليله
مباركه جبريل عليه
السلام
open point was
considered propet is he was first
الله سبحانه
وتالى سوره
المدثر يا ايها المدثر قم فانذر وربك فكبر
وثيابك فطهر والرجز
فاهجر ولا ولا تمنن تستكثر ولربك فاصبر
صلى الله عليه
وسلم قم
فانذر
call and
warn
mean warn humanity warn the people
of ابن القيم ‏say at this point when
these
veres he was nowo as a
messenger what's the difference we
discuss this in detail many sessions ag
many classes ag but a very brief
recap what is a prophet what is a
messenger a prophet and
messenger differ opin among schar isam
‏all the way back to the time
the عنه we look all the verses of the
قران all the narration we look at
nuances
distinction between prophet and
messenger we notice something and that
is the schar say the key difference
‏prophet is could be sent messenger sent
but the key difference is whom they are
sent to a messenger is sent to those who
do not believe in islam those are not
upon the religion of the
props they are idol they are you know
astrologers whatever it is
‏of all the prophet
and لام الله سبحانه
وتالى disbeliever who are who have from
الله سبحانه
وتالى iah iah was aeng نح was
messenger لت عليه السلام شعيب
صح allengers
[Silence]
‏upon
messenger the messenger com before them
so for instance we have عليه السلام we
سان are
props م عليه
الس عليه السلام
عليه
السلام يف عليه
السلام why heent to the people of egyt
after arrival there
الغير ع عليه
السلام موسى عليه
السلامون عليه السلام ‏was adam a prophet
was adam a messenger this
oftentimes is a point of confusion for
some
people and that is yes adam عليه was a
propet in the that heed revelation from
الله سبحانه وتالى either in form spe or
revelation through angels he was not a
messenger meaning sent to a disbelieving
people
‏was
not العلماء يختلفون
كثيرا كثيرا قديما وحديثا في التفرقه بين
النبي
والرسول بعض العلماء قال لك النبي والرسول
نفس الشيء ما في فرق وهذا قول الامام
الطبري رحمه الله تعالى في
التفسير لكن الذي استقر
عليه راي
الجمهور و
المحققين من
العلماء ان النبي
والرسول في
فرق وذلك انهم يقولون الرسول ارفع درجه
واخص من
النبي ومن ذلك يقولون مقوله
معروفه كل رسول نبي وليس كل نبي
رسولا طيب اذا اثبتنا الفرق بين النبي
والرسول الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول وما
ارسلنا من رسول ولا
نبي اذا في فرق بين النبي
والرسول فما الفرق ما هو تعريف الرسول
وتعريف النبي العلماء اختلفوا في هذا
كثيرا والامر وفي بينهما عموم وخصوص
وتداخل يعني صفات للانبياء موجوده في في
الرسل وصفات للرسل بعضها موجوده في
الانبياء
لكن الفاصل
بينهما ان الرسول من ارسل الى
قوم
محاربين قوم كفار ليسوا على دين
الانبياء واما
النبي فاذا كان نبيا وليس رسولا
فعاده يكون من اوحي
اليه وبعث الى قوم موافقين له في اصل
الدين فالرسول من ارسل الى قوم اوحي اليه
و وامر
بالتبليغ وارسل الى قوم
مخالفين له في اصل الد اصل الدين يعني لا
اله الا الله هم يخالفونه على هذا واما
النبي فهو من اوحي اليه ولم يؤمر بالتبليغ
او امر
بالتبليغ لقوم موافقين
له في اصل
الدين ابن القيم
صلى الله عليه
وسلم سه العلق اقرا بسم ربك الذي
خلق يا اي المدثر ق
فان
was call
‏and so he warn he warned
his his confid his wife his
cin
cl الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم
announced that aeng
‏andit his people to islam and this was
the whole
of and so he call his people
islam village or city of
me and then he start to call those tries
are
ne and so
‏ande
out
gr and that is how in our life should be
we start with ourselves and then those
whom we have most influence over and we
end
up calling and teaching and so forth
strangers way later down the
road after this he started to
‏call is
all tri
allin even the arab
peninsula after this he was commanded
and he began toite
is
all ابن
القم
andes in dealing with his
antagon ‏he spent 13
years calling to islam without any
type of violence and when we say
violence we don't mean attacking
necessarily meaning using violence to
repel violence using force using force
to protect using force to invest
whatever it is 13 years
‏and he was comm
time and and overl and be patient
patient with any antagon with anyone
that he faces in
difficulty after this he was commanded
and alled to make he migrated from me
the dynamic ch ‏his migration why
because he was migrating from a hostile
majority living as as a as
a repressed minority amongst a
majority or hle
majority where he arrived in me
to a place where the muslims became the
maity ‏and the hostiles were either on
good terms or they
were not part of the state at that time
there was either a peace or a pct or a
treaty he says and then after this he
was permitted to use
force and then he was
commanded to fight against those who
fight ‏against him first was def and
then it was off now offensive warfare
most of the time in a healthy state is
defensive you know if you wait to be
attacked or you wait until something
becomes a clear blat threat it's
probably too late to
defend much
‏much the warf place his time
and very large portion of
the armies that he sent to battle and
that he was in these were
defensive military
these were defensive they were
designed as defense either to defend
‏those
islam this was
the
ma especially at the begin
of when wared to be a of the
state only
‏only a person who is deliberately
misunderstanding would
ب صلى الله عليه
وسلم اسلام spread by the
sword this is a deliberate
misunderstanding there is no
st that pr
‏have to have a military as part of the
structure of their state it has to
be and we have this notion you know in
america which is paradoxical because
it's very ironic one of the biggest
militaries in the whole
world the authors of you know
extreme war and blooded throughout the
centuries we have
‏that muslim
areed
toed accept or defend prop صل الله عليه
وسلم from statements isam spre by
the sword meaning that people forced to
become muslim that's what that means and
that couldn't be further from the truth
there no such thing as a
prosperous anybody
‏except that people other people will
des har for
that that is the way the world
is and especially for a prophet a
messenger every messenger has an enemy
historically and so there is no and
people who have experien
‏people are
violent
because they understand they just they
mean you harm and there is nothing in
the world that you can say to them to
talk them out of that
hostility as a matter of trying to talk
them out of their hostility usually only
serves to increase
هذ سنه الله في
الارض وذلك ان الله تعالى يقول ولولا دفع
الله الناس بعضهم ببعض لفسدت
الارض لكن الله ذو فضل على العالمين
‏and humanity in
general
prospers
from healthy warfare warfare that is
waged for the right
reasons denouncing
warfare is to denounce most of
modernity most the we have to
‏they
deved
military proprietary to the military in
order to get an edge on there on their
antagon or their
enemies everything most of the things
that you and i use every microwaves use
microwave to make breakfast that was a
military
invention penic
‏aned
byit
forit you know things airplan
celles the internet these are all
military
inventions what caus these things to be
invented
competition
competition they are with
those who they enem
‏try to ed over the other and this is
these are some of the prosperi that come
to humanity from this however there is
healthy warfare which is necessary evil
and then there is warfare for the sake
of bloods and genocide
and dominance
and
and invasion and so for this is a very
صلى الله عليه
وسلم was ne any ضي الله
عنه if you
say give us one sentence or one
narration صلى الله عليه وسلم
وي
ميت يعني لو اخذنا حديثا واحدا او مقوله
للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم تشخص لنا
باختصار وتختصر
لنا حال فتوحات النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
مع اعدائه
ما هو الحديث وما هي
المقوله النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم لما كان في السنه السابعه او
الثامنه فاتحا
لمكه وقد اعطى
اللواء لسعد بن عباده رضي الله عنه من
الانصار
و مر
سعد رضي الله عنه عن ابي
سفيان وهم
يدخلون ابواب
مكه فيما
وصفه الواصفون بكتيبه الحديد فلما مر عليه
قال
اليوم يوم اذل الله فيه
قريشا يعني يتشاف منه لانه حقيقه
قريش
والمشركون يعني غلبوا المسلمين كثيرا
واذوه وقتلوهم و نقضوا العهود ونقضوا
العهد مع الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وهذا
كان سبب فتح مكه
اصلا نقضوا عهد الحديبيه عننا كانت الشروط
على المسلمين في صالح المشركين في الظاهر
وشروط المشركين في صالح المشركين ومع
ذلك فانهم نقضوا
العهد فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخبر
بمقوله سعد قال اليوم يوم اذل الله فيه
قريشا فامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم باخذ
اللواء من سعد ودفعه الى ابنه
لانه راد اللواء ان يبقى في في داره وفي
بيته لكن اخذ اللواء امر باخذ اللواء من
سعد لماذا لان هذه النفسيه هي ليست
نفسيه فتوحات النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ثم ماذا قال قال بل هذا يوم اعز الله
فيه
قريش اعزهم كيف يعني جيبوا لي فاتح في
تاريخ الدنيا ياتي يفتح مدينه او قوما
ويقول هذا يوم اعزكم الله
فيه لكن هو ياتي عليه السلام رحمه
للعالمين وكذلك
كان الامر كما قال يوم عزه
لقريش اصبحوا ساده الدنيا و
كان القران لهم ذكرا بعد هذا اليوم ل هذا
يشخص فتوحات النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ليست فتوحات مبنيه على ما في اذهان الناس
في الغرب في الذين لهم تاريخ دموي يعني
فعلا تاريخ اسود ملطخ
بالدماء ويظن ان الفتوحات التي كانت لرسول
لله
وللمسلمين انها بنفس النفسيه بنفس
بنفس
المجرمين
الذين ياتون لاضطهاد
الاقوام ولقتل والتطهير العرقي وما شابه
ذلك مما نراه ممن استحو عليهم
الشيطان و
ان شاء
الله next نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم
وصلى الله عل وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله